there's another burden that comes with
this whole intelligence thing that
humans got is uh
the extinguishing
of the light of consciousness which is
uh kind of realizing that we're gonna be
dead someday
and there's a bunch of philosophers like
ernest becker
who kind of think that this
realization of mortality
and then
fear sometimes they call it terror
of
of of mortality is one of the creative
forces
behind
human condition like it's the thing that
drives us do you think it's important
for an ai system you know when psych
proposed that it's one it's not human
and is one of the moderators of his
contents
um
you know there's another question you
could ask which is like it kind of knows
that humans are mortal
am immortal
and i think one really important
uh thing that's possible when you're
conscious
is to fear the extinguishing of that
consciousness the fear of mortality
do you think that's useful for
intelligence
thinking like i might die and i really
don't want to die i i don't think so i
think it may help
some humans
to be
better people it may help some humans to
be more creative
and so on i don't think it's necessary
for ais to
believe that they have limited life
spans and therefore they should make the
most of their behavior maybe eventually
um the answer to that and my answer to
that will change but as of now i would
say that that's almost like a a frill or
a side effect that
is not in fact if you look at most
humans most humans
ignore the fact that they're going to
die most of the time
so
well but that's like
this goes to the white space between the
words
so what ernest beckham argues is that
that ignoring is we're living an
illusion that we're constructed on the
foundation of this terror so we're
escape life as we know it
pursuing things creating things love
everything we can think of that's
beautiful about humanity is is just
trying to escape this realization that
we're going to die one day that's his
that's his idea and i think i don't know
if i i 100
believe in this but there's it certainly
rhymes it seems like to me like it
rhymes with the truth
yeah i i think that for some people
um
that's gonna be a more powerful
factor than others clearly doug is
talking about russians
and
i think that uh
some russians so it clearly it
infiltrates all of russian literature
and ai doesn't have to have
uh fear of death as a motivating force
in that we can build in
motivation so we can build in the
motivation of
obeying users and making users happy and
making others happy and
and so on and
that can substitute for this sort of
personal fear of death that sometimes
leads to
bursts of creativity and in humans i
don't know i think like i think ai
really needs to understand death deeply
in order to be able to drive a car for
example
i i think there's just some
like there no i really disagree i think
it needs to understand the value of
human life especially the value of human
life to other humans
the um and understand that certain
things are more important than other
things it has to have a lot of knowledge
about ethics and
morality and so on but some of it is so
messy that it's impossible to encode for
example this
is disagree
so if there's a person dying right in
front of us
most human beings would help that person
but they would not apply that same
ethics to everybody else in the world
this is the tragedy of how difficult it
is to be a doctor
because they know when they help a dying
child
they know that the money they're
spending on this child
cannot possibly be spent on every other
child that's dying and that's
that's a very difficult to encode
decision
now
perhaps perhaps it is perhaps they could
be formalized oh but i mean you're
talking about
autonomous vehicles right so
autonomous vehicles are going to have to
make those decisions
um all the time of um what is the chance
of this bad event happening um how bad
is that compared to this chance of that
bad event happening and so on and you
know when a potential accident is about
to happen is it worth taking this risk
if i have to make a choice which of
these two cars am i going to hit and why
and see i was thinking about a very
different choice when i'm talking about
hero mortality which is just observing
uh manhattan style driving
i think that humans as an effective
driver needs to threaten
pedestrians lives a lot
there's a dance i've watched pedestrians
a lot of i worked on this problem and it
seems like
the the if i could summarize the problem
of a pedestrian crossing
is
the car with this movement is saying i'm
going to kill you and the pedestrian is
saying
maybe and then they decide to say no i
don't think you you have the guts to
kill me and you walk and they walk in
front and they look away
and there's that dance
the the the pedestrian as this the
social contract
that the pedestrian trusts that once
they're in front of the car and the car
is sufficiently from a physics
perspective able to stop they're going
to stop but the car also has to threaten
that pedestrians like i'm late for work
so you're being kind of an [ __ ] by
crossing in front of me but life and
death is in like is part of the
calculation here and it's that that
equation is being solved millions of
times a day
yes very effectively that game theory
whatever yeah whatever that formulation
absolutely i just i don't know if it's
as simple as some
formalizable game theory problem it
could very well be in the case of
driving and in the case of most of
uh
human society i i don't know but
it uh yeah you might be right that sort
of the fear of death is just one of the
quirks
of uh like the way our brains have
evolved but it's not it's not a
necessary feature of intelligence
drivers certainly are always doing this
kind of estimate even if it's
unconscious subconscious
of
what are the chances of various bad
outcomes happening like for instance
if i don't wait for this pedestrian or
something like that and
what is the downside to me going to be
in terms of um you know time wasted
talking to the police or um you know
getting sent to jail or you know things
like that and so
um and there's also emotion like people
in their cars tend to get
uh irrationally angry that's that's
that's dangerous but you know think
think about this is all part of why i
think that autonomous vehicles um truly
autonomous vehicles are farther out
than than most people do because
there is this enormous level of
complexity which goes beyond
mechanically controlling the car
and
i i can see the autonomous vehicles as a
kind of metaphorical and literal
accident waiting to happen
and not just because of
their um overall
incurring versus preventing accidents
and so on but just because of the
almost
voracious appetite people have
for
bad
bad stories about powerful companies and
powerful entities when when i was um
at a coincidentally japanese fifth
generation computing system conference
in 1987
while i happened to be there
there was a worker at an auto plant who
was despondent and committed suicide by
climbing under the safety chains and so
on getting stamped to death by a machine
and instead of being a small story that
said despondent worker commits suicide
it was front page news that effectively
said
robot kills worker
because the public is just waiting
for stories about like
a.i kills phonogenic family of five type
stories and even if you could show that
nationwide
this system saved more lives than it
cost and saved more injuries
prevented more injuries than it caused
and so on
the media the public the government is
just
coiled and ready to pounce
on stories where in fact it failed even
if they're relatively few
yeah it's so fascinating to watch us
humans resisting
the cutting edge of science and
technology and almost like hoping for it
to fail and constantly and you know
this just happens over and over and over
throughout history or even if we're not
hoping for it to fail we're we're
fascinated by it and in terms of what we
find interesting
um the one in a thousand failures much
more interesting than the 999
boring successes
you